now Lithuania this month became the Envy
of the EU when it announced it had
completely stopped importing gas from
Russia it was able to pull the plug on
Russian energy things to its investment
in a terminal to import liquefied
natural gas or LNG with the fitting name
Independence
every month tank ships filled with
liquefied natural gas head to Lithuania
by the Baltic Sea one full LNG carrier
is all it takes to supply the country's
2.8 million people with gas for half a
month
we've been invited to take a peek at the
high-tech floating LNG terminal that
makes it possible in the port city of
clipeda
before the terminal in Albania and the
Baltic states have been paying the
highest price in whole Europe
approximately up to 40 percent more just
because we did not have an alternative
after the independent started operations
in the region we have natural gas prices
became just the same as in the Western
Europe
the terminal was called Independence
because it makes Lithuania completely
independent of Russian gas which until
recently was delivered via pipelines
filming in the terminal and the port is
prohibited due to fears of Russian
sabotage
the LNG comes from Norway the US and the
Gulf States the gas which is cooled down
to minus 160 degrees Celsius for
shipping is converted back to gas and
fed into lithuania's grid through
underground Pipelines
could such a floating terminal also make
Germany independent of Russian gas
I don't see any reason why it would not
be feasible for example the fania
natural gas consumption annual
consumption is approximately 2 billion
cubic meters and this specific vessel
has a capacity of 3.75 so that means
that it can supply elephania and
neighboring countries with natural gas
it took two years to build the terminal
which will be expanded it won't only
make Lithuania independent of Russian
gas but will also help the Baltic states
Supply neighboring countries with LNG
that will be done by this Gas
Distribution plant close to the capital
Vilnius from here LNG flows to
lithuania's neighbors the operator is
preparing for increased demand
this place actually is connected to the
new gas pipeline that is being under a
very finishing touches and we will start
it on the 1st of May towards Poland gas
interconnection between Poland and
Lithuania it's now easy for Lithuania
Poland Estonia Latvia and Finland to
swap their gas reserves so they have
much better chances of making it through
a Russian gas embargo
while other countries hope to follow
Lithuania the EU as a whole remains
heavily dependent on Russian gas earlier
I spoke to Michael stopper Chief
strategist for Global gas at IHS Market
about whether LNG is a realistic
replacement for the rest of the block
well it does take time to not only build
run put in place re-gas terminals but
indeed the entire infrastructure of the
entire supply chain for LNG I think with
regard to those regas terminals it will
be a struggle to get them up and running
by the beginning of winter but probably
should be up and running before the end
of winter
so give us a sense of of the situation
right now for for energy Security in
Europe do we have enough natural gas to
get us through the coming months the
coming year
well first the first thing to say is
that the uh Russian gas which of course
is such an important percentage share of
the European mix is continuing to flow
it's flowing through the north stream
Pipeline and and flowing across
Ukrainian uh territory into into Europe
so the gas is coming from Europe and
from other sources from Algeria from
Norway and from LNG
um the our second Point that's very
important to remember is the winter is
now behind us we're well into spring and
gas demand across Europe is declining
very sharply so the key issue now
becomes uh preparing the storage build
that's required over the next six months
to prepare for winter and indeed getting
those regas terminals in place to
prepare ourselves for winter so we have
a six month preparation period it's very
important to make maximum use of
I mean given how expensive LNG is how
realistic is it that that will play a
major role in the EU energy Supply going
forward
I think LNG will play a critical role I
mean the entire energy complex is
extremely stretched so prices are very
high but the cost structure of LNG is
well below the current very high level
so if we get more investment we can see
uh competitive prices emerging but that
will take some years as we adjust from
this very high level of use of Russian
Pipeline and we move to Greater use of
LNG we do need to recall that the LNG
Market is truly Global and there are
major economies most notably Japan and
South Korea that are dependent 100 for
their natural gas from LNG so EUR is
competing for that Supply from other
sources and it will take four or five
years to get a supply response before
new projects are up to meet to meet the
required demand but lmd will be one of
the critical elements for diversifying
the the European gas supplies late